más de 60 años separan este desfile de
la feria de las flores de la primera vez
en que los silleteros llegaron a
medellín a mostrar su arte pero la
tradición data de siglos atrás cuando
estas viñetas que ustedes ven a mis
costados se usaban para llevar a
personas enfermas heridas mujeres
embarazadas e incluso fueron usadas por
los esclavos para cargarse a sus amos
sin embargo esta tradición fue mutando y
recoge un saber campesino en donde por
ejemplo llevan las flores para
comercializarlas en estas grietas pasado
el tiempo se convirtió en el arte que
pueden ver ustedes en estas silletas del
festival de 2022 en medellín acá tengo a
uno de los silleteros que se llama
felipe y le va a preguntar para usted
por qué es importante este desfile para
mí es importante ese desfile porque ya
superamos la pandemia y porque volvemos
a sentir ese calor humano de las
personas que siempre nos han acompañado
y siempre hacen que esa tradición siga
permanente en mis dientes tal como uno
dice felipe es una tradición que pasa de
generación en generación y permite que
500 personas 500 silleteros participen
en esta edición que muestra una vez más
porque a medellín
a la ciudad de la eterna primavera